es ist so peinlich war möchte echt im
boden versinken wir deutschen haben die
klimakonferenz man muss sagen vermasselt
die ärmeren regionen der erde fühlen
sich allein gelassen
fragwürdig war vor allem der deutsche
auftritt hier wurde deutlich der
damalige vorreiter in sachen
klimapolitik hat mehr als ein paar
kratzer abbekommen wir machen den
faktencheck was hat die bonner
klimakonferenz wirklich gebracht und wie
wird der kampf gegen den klimawandel
jetzt konkret weitergehen das alles
jetzt den blick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
heute aus berlin die klimakonferenz vor
zwei jahren in paris war mit einem
großen versprechen beendet die ganze
welt staunte als die teilnehmenden
staaten damals versprachen die erwärmung
der erde auf einen wert deutlich unter
zwei grad celsius zu stoppen ein
ehrgeiziges aber längst überfällige
statement und irgendwie war klar dass
der gipfel in bonn nicht daran reichen
könnte denn sind wir mal ehrlich die
selbst gesteckten ziele der 190
teilnehmenden staaten waren
minimalistisch man wollte irgendwie die
umsetzung des pariser abkommens weiter
nach vorne bringen und ja das hat auch
in teilen geklappt es gibt nun einen
ersten entwurf für ein regelbuch das
beschreibt wie das pariser abkommen ab
2020 in die tat umgesetzt werden kann
das muss jetzt soweit gekürzt werden
dass es 2018 im polnischen kattowitz
final beschlossen und unterzeichnet
werden kann ein erfolg zum feiern ist
das noch lange nicht aber es gibt einige
punkte die in bonn abgehakt werden
konnten die vielleicht größte erfolg in
bonn der druck auf die welt aus der
klimaschädlichen kohle auszusteigen ist
gestiegen kanada und großbritannien
haben den start einer globalen
initiative verkündet sie wollen zusammen
mit 20 anderen partnern den ausstieg aus
der kohle angehen und die macht immerhin
noch rund 40 prozent der
energieversorgung weltweit aus dabei
sind unter anderem mexiko frankreich und
italien mehr als peinlich für uns
deutschland ist nicht bei diesem anti
kohle bündnis dabei und da flippe ich
wirklich aus wenn christian lindner von
der fdp bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
in berlin befürchtet dass wir durch die
abschaltung von kohlekraftwerken zum
stromimporteur 'nen genau von solchen
klimaschädlichen kohlestrom werden und
atomkraft dann wirft das ein
erschreckendes bild auf die fdp von
tuten und blasen keine ahnung und die
wollen die geschicke der bundesrepublik
deutschland bestimmen ob man das stimmt
nämlich nicht wir brauchen die kohle
verstromung einzig und allein für die
netzstabilität und da zeigt ja gerade
ihnen masken australien wie man das
einfach und smart mit batterie farben
lösen kann
lieberlieber christian lindner erst
informieren dann reden da wird einem
echt angst und bange um deutschland
deutschland hat in bonn eine andere
initiative präsentiert demnach sollen
arme und betroffene menschen weltweit
gegen klimaschäden versichert werden
extreme wetterlagen in diesem jahr wie
die hurricanes in der karibik oder die
dürren in teilen afrikas könnten
zu führen dass 2017 ein neues rekordjahr
wird ein rekord an schäden durch
ebensolche extremwetterlagen und die
treffen vor allem die menschen in den
ärmeren regionen dieser welt und rauben
ihnen ihre komplette existenz die
deutsche bundesregierung will helfen und
nennt die mögliche lösung interesse lenz
das bündnis bei dem auch andere länder
mitmachen soll also armen menschen
helfen sich gegen wetterkatastrophen zu
wappnen das konkrete ziel bis 2020
sollen 400 millionen menschen gegen
klimaschäden versichert sein
daumen hoch für diese idee ein erfolg im
weiteren sinne war außerdem dass ein
alternatives bündnis aus us
bundesstaaten städte und firmen die
offizielle us delegation in den schatten
gestellt hat auch wenn donald trump
plant aus dem pariser abkommen
auszutreten war das zeichen dieser
allianz in bonn deutlich große teile der
usa sind weiter dabei sie wollen das
pariser versprechen erfüllen der
austritt der usa spielt so überhaupt
keine rolle mehr auch gut immerhin
festzuhalten also das pariser abkommen
ist nicht geschichte soll fortgeführt
und umgesetzt werden der trend weg von
kohle ist ungebrochen man will weiterhin
darüber sprechen wie man noch
ehrgeiziger klimapolitik machen kann
2018 soll der sogenannte thaler noah
dialog stattfinden bei dem auch
umweltschützer und klima wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen teilnehmen oft
sind ja nur die üblichen diplomaten und
diplomatinnen eingeladen lange hatten
die teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen über
wichtige finanzfragen gestritten
eigentlich sollten die konferenz am
freitag enden
erst am frühen samstag morgen einigte
man sich dann doch darauf dass ein
älterer milliarden schwerer form wohl
fortbestehen soll
der soll armen ländern dabei helfen
klimafolgen zu bewältigen die chancen
sind jetzt größer geworden dass dieser
form wohl auch nach dem ablauf des
kyoto-protokolls 2020 weiterlaufen soll
viele klima diplomaten und politiker
feiern den klimagipfel im bund deswegen
als erfolg ganz anders dagegen sehen
dass die vertreter derjenigen regionen
die schon jetzt unmittelbar vom
klimawandel betroffen sind zum beispiel
bei geely nicole wir stehen an der
frontlinie des klimawandels in ihrer
heimat den fidschi inseln mussten schon
jetzt ganze dörfer umsiedeln den
menschen dort steht wortwörtlich das
wasser bis zum hals auch entwicklungs
organisationen wie oxfam sind enttäuscht
und kritisieren
dass die reichen industrieländer noch
immer viel zu wenig verantwortung
übernehmen oxfam mitarbeiter jan
kowalzig sagt die wachsenden schäden und
zerstörungen in folge von dürren stürmen
und anderen um wetterextremen dringend
gerade die kleinen inselstaaten
zunehmend in existenzielle nöte auch
finanzieller art hier haben die
industrieländer zwei wochen gemauert und
nun erfolgreich verhindert die
finanzierungsfragen im umgang mit
verlusten und schäden infolge des
klimawandels auf kommenden konferenzen
den nötigen raum zu geben das ist ein
übles manöver gegenüber den ärmsten und
vom klimawandel extrem bedrohten ländern
der klimawandel in bonn hat vor allem
eins gezeigt der vorreiter der
deutschland einmal beim klimaschutz war
hat nicht nur einige kratzer abbekommen
kaum erreichbar scheint das ziel die
treibhausgase bis 2020 gegenüber 1990 um
40 prozent zu reduzieren
davon haben wir bisher nur 28 prozent
geschafft stattdessen ist deutschland
kurz davor abgehängt zu werden
deutschland ist weltweit der größte
förderer von braunkohle sieben der zehn
schlimmsten co2 schleudern in europa
stehen bei uns bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel reagiert darauf mehr als
ausreichend die interessen von
wirtschaft und klimaschutz müssten
sorgfältig bedacht werden
in ihrer rede in bonn hat sie zwar einen
schnelleren ausstieg aus der kohlekraft
angedeutet wohlgemerkt angedeutet
gleichzeitig betonte sie aber auch dass
braunkohle auch weiterhin einen
wesentlichen beitrag zur
energiegewinnung leisten soll ja echt
bullshit gleichzeitig wird es auf der
erde immer wärmer und das was im
klimaschutz bisher vereinbart wurde
reicht nicht aus um uns zu retten
deutschland blamiert sich damit so
dramatisch auf internationaler bühne
wenn wir etwas versprechen ja dann
können wir es nicht halten so gesehen
weil der klimagipfel in bonn schon fast
eine farce sind auch wenn hier nicht die
wirklich großen streitfragen besprochen
wurden ans eingemachte ging es nicht
müsste in dieser situation in der wir
uns gerade befinden nicht hart und
unerbittlich diskutiert werden das hat
auf jeden fall nicht stattgefunden es
war ringelpiez mit anfassen denn die
großen probleme wurden nicht weiter
angegangen
wenn ihr in zukunft kein video zum thema
verpassen wollt dann drücken wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst er kein video wenn er hier
drauf klickt geht es weiter mit
klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker endgültig
widerlegt an
johnston bis dann bleibt dran